a a bell curve right in the beginning
nobody cares about Bitcoin so who the
Creator is doesn't matter then you get
into a highly speculative phase probably
actually around seventeen and eighteen
when literally like media companies
we're trying to figure it out they
really want to know and then you get on
the other side of the bell curve and
bitcoin is Bitcoin and people don't care
about the creation story as much anymore
because it's just this thing that they
use right and as time goes on cut the
history doesn't matter totally I mean I
don't think most people can could tell
you who built the internet absolutely
basically would look at it what are your
thoughts on on various other aspects of
of crypto so things like defy other
blockchains
anything that you're interested in an
understanding that you know you're
probably very similar to me if like
bitcoin is the king and there's really
kind of the main focus of a lot of this
but is there anything else that you're
kind of looking at saying hey that's
interesting yeah so I believe that big
that blockchain was special-purpose
built it to build Bitcoin I wrote an
article that was a comprehensive
analysis of Bitcoin security model as
people remember earlier in this
conversation I talked about how miners
are rewarded with that block reward when
you look at how this is all constructed
blockchain technology is very bad at
doing almost everything like it's not
this general-purpose toughest one tool
for all things it's block chains
sacrifice and have trade-offs and those
sacrifices and trade-offs are really bad
I mean it'd be you basically sacrifice
everything to have a sound money and to
have a goal to point out and so you know
we could look at it from that
perspective which is that a blockchain
inherently can do many things due to how
it's built
due to the intricate maker nature of how
it all works also we can look at the
empirical data we can look at the 10,000
dead crypto currencies and go or crypto
projects and go okay well it seems like
all of these failed and their hypothesis
was that there are other use cases for
blockchain attack I think most
blockchain and tech out there now is
basically trying to mimic the wealth
effect of Bitcoin by
producing a narrative that resonates
etherium is a good example
atheria Marta Daz ADAP platform now they
came out with that because that
resonates very well with tech people I
live in San Francisco I've been here for
80 years tech people hear the word DAP
and they go oh an app and app apps and
app you know platforms app stores and
apps
oh this is the new Apple but for
decentralized you know D central
decentralized nature and so Silicon
Valley wholeheartedly embraced etherion
because they fundamentally don't
understand sound of money or gold or the
economic system at all they understand
apps but as we saw that was a I would
consider a gross grossly misinterpreted
or grossly marketed narrative because
there's no way you can scale an
application honorarium right like as
soon as we sell crypto please get any
sort of meaningful attraction which
meaningful attraction means 10,000 users
I've built a couple side-project apps
that have $10 users those were something
I work on on the weekend like this
negligible not even anything material
right I've worked at uber I was on
writer growth which is that writer rap
as the app that you all call uber I was
working on that team with Andrew Chen
like we're looking at metrics that are
10 to a hundred million right and so you
know this this DAT platform a narrative
was basically fake and so that
dissipated fundraising platform
narrative and 2017 for aetherium that
also dissipated and now aetherium the
etherium community is pivoting to sound
money [ __ ] kidding me what this is
nuts I mean I remember going to suppose
roundtable in 2015 the first one and
they're all talking about aetherium
being this dap platform and now they're
talking about it being a sound money is
crazy so we're seeing in one of the
oldest alternative use cases for
blockchain tech we're seeing their
narrative pivot to sound money so I
think overall like the only surviving
narrative here is probably going to be a
sound money or money narrative as we see
that blockchain tech work very well with
other things now of course this is my
personal opinion doesn't represent
not my employers but yeah just just
personally how I think about it there's